[Music]
[Applause]
the names flag master 64 I'm a level 3
you to be around I do work hard in my
videos today I'm gonna work hard or make
it better for everyone I'm not the hero
their YouTube needs and the hero he
deserves
when I first became a you to be arrow it
was the happiest day of my life almost
like being a real youtuber but without
putting any of the effort
[Music]
Paris extra for Python the be we go
it's n des mots two million in culture
the also health news our alliance tea
so her Fuhrer with the level three flag
system don't you think people might
abuse they finebros what do you have to
say the confusion and negative response
over what this all is has been so
overwhelming but again it's very very
complex and we also know that there's so
many more questions oh wow I didn't
realize you're the ones that came up
with his system yes
[Music]
You Tube heroes it seems that all
youtubers absolutely hate this new
feature but do they really right now at
this point [ __ ] on YouTube is just
generating views so that's just what
people are gonna do
I would never [ __ ] on YouTube reviews
just look at leafy the end of YouTube is
here the death of YouTube now that seems
a little exaggerated don't you think
maybe just tiny love it I mean I would
never [ __ ] on YouTube that's us against
my core principle and core message take
your hand off me
[Music]
[Applause]
Oh